may be the beautiful game but it's not
looking so good for the fight against
covert
it's feared that sunday's euro 2020
final could result in a huge
spike in cases as the victorious italian
team
paraded their trophy through the centre
of rome little thought was being given
to covert regulations by the enormous
crowds
and that came just a day after tens of
thousands of unmasked fans crammed
together during the match
in london the world health organization
has described the event
as devastating am i supposed to be
enjoying watching transmission happening
in front of my eyes
the kovite 19 pandemic is not taking a
break tonight
sarsko v2 delta variant will take
advantage of unvaccinated people
in crowded settings unmasked screaming
shouting singing
devastating
[Applause]
[Music]
well 60 000 fans barely a mask to be
seen a lack of social distancing no
checks and claims of fake test results
that was the scene playing out at
wembley stadium
sports journalist derek clark who was at
the game says that covert controls were
quite simply
a joke it turns out that you didn't even
need to
do or fake a test because you weren't
even checked for your
your covered test whatsoever and like
you say they were just checking your
your your phone for you your ticket and
the qr code
once you've seen that you had a ticket
on your phone uh they were just allowing
you in
uh it doesn't matter if you had a
negative test or if you you maybe faked
it the test either but
i certainly think more really could have
been done i think they should have taken
it more seriously there's no checks
for covered in place um there was just a
a large surge of people with more robust
security measures
should have been in place as well but
there just wasn't enough
security or steers to carry out the
checks
healthcare officials have warned the
euro 2020 finals could see the uk
heading towards a million
new infections within a month right now
cases have shot up to around 35
000 a day but the prime minister is
still going ahead with his plan to
remove most restrictions in england next
week
however the government says it's all due
to a successful vaccination program
that's seen
almost 35 million people receive a jab
we will stick to our plan to lift legal
restrictions
and to lift social distancing derek
clark
again who was at that tense final
between england and italy fears that a
spike of cases is indeed on the horizon
the restrictions are easy uh the 19th of
july of course is when
uh looking at the final restrictions
easing as well so things aren't getting
back to normal
but very little people wearing masks
um last night and especially
heading towards the underground station
after the game
a large amount of people but no real
mask wearing so
you do worry that there could be a rise
in cases
because of that then as i mentioned
earlier no checks for
covid heading into the ground so there
is a worry that
i mean i was in the ground just about 20
minutes and there was
already three or four young guys it's
already burst in
you